[Musik]
früher und es ist auch jetzt noch so am
wochenende gesagt wenn die ferien sind
ist das sowieso ein kleiner ausflug mit
der familie
wenn irgend weiss essen fahren oder ich
werde jetzt sagen tierpark oder sonst
was aber die sind hierher gekommen die
kinder sprinten nach oben und der junge
in die spielecke das mädel guckt sich
die barbie filme an
papa koop action und noch mal guckt der
liebesfilm und dann treffen sie sich und
eine halle und dem popcorn kauf und
getränke und dann waren die alle nach
hause und jeder hat seinen teil wasser
haben will um den nachmittag zu
gestalten und den abend und dann ist das
so ein kleines erlebnis gewesen
und so sollte es ja eigentlich auch
sehen ist und auch den großen laden hier
damals ausgebaut weil man sagen wir
wollten alles im angebot haben wir
wollten das groß und nicht so ein
kleines loch wie früher mit engen gängen
und das team durch die familie mit rein
darf auch nicht normal für die ersten
videotheken waren ja auch dürften keine
kinder mit 3 1
das kommen wir sind immer die gleichen
über die familie gekommen und die wissen
dann schon mal die kids bully hinrennen
und die wissen auch wie jeder film steht
die sagen mir das dann schon dass er
denn das macht schon spaß und folgt man
sich wieder das ist mein baum anders
mein name ist marco panzer ich arbeite
seit 29 jahren als video tk in dieser
videothek arbeite seit 2004 bei der
firma video wollte
in der filme habe ich gerne gesehene zu
auszeiten schon unterbruch die ersten
rocky filme kassettenrekorder zu ddr
zeiten aufgenommen und nachts die
kassetten gehört mit kopfhörern im bett
und den film noch mal gesehen
bei videorekorder gab es hier nicht
[Musik]
naja wenn man erst mal so ein bisschen
saugen oder laden ist auch ganz schön
groß dann räume auf die kühlschränke
nach getränke nachfüllen sehr gut weg
packen post sortieren und den
aufschließen und dann geht es los
[Musik]
in cottbus gab es mal über 25
videotheken
ansonsten gab es eigentlich in jedem
kleinen nest gab es schon früher eine
videothek in den letzten fünf jahren hat
sich das alles nach hinten entwickelt
die letzten vier jahre wandern also da
ging es richtig bergab
wir arbeiten schon darauf hin dass wir
wissen dass es nicht mehr ewig gehen
wird aber wir versuchen das alles so
lange die rechnung noch bezahlen können
was immer schwerer wird machen wir das
und wenn das dann nicht mehr geht dann
muss man das licht ausmachen
ja meistens machst du noch einen großen
abverkauf tust dann alles verkaufen was
du da hast ein leute kommen und denn es
ist halt weg und dann ganz abschließen
[Musik]
kann man ja mal stehen machen das ist
heute wo es hat sich so entwickelt
die leute haben andere interessen
die gucken sich was ich mit ihrem handy
sind die was ich auf den social media
kramer und einen ganzen tag unterwegs
und mit whatsapp kommen nach hause ich
habe meinen kinder angeben müssen dann
erst mal zwei stunden mit ihrem handy
rumspielt können nicht mal rot essen und
da ist die zeit natürlich weg so wie
früher um sich den film genommen haben
und mit kumpels getroffen haben und das
gibt es halt nicht mehr so sind noch
ganz viele stammkunden
diese sind die die das jetzt noch so ein
bisschen hoch halten im sommer die dann
auch fast nur um sommer kommen die
wirklich film interesse haben die
mehrmals kommen oder immer die woche
oder hast du schon ganz viele die
meisten kennste persönlich wenn sie
reinkommen da brauchst du eine
kundenkarte mehr
das ist schon und die sind auch bunt
filmisch das ist jede altersklasse und
gibt ja auch viele leute die jetzt sag
ich mal aus dem umland kommen hier her
die in burg wurden oder sonstwas und
nicht so einen schnellen
internetanschluss haben und da haben die
gar keine andere möglichkeit
bei uns kostet jeder film ein euro pro
tag
die preise haben sich bei uns gar nicht
geändert wenn ich das so machen muss
also wir haben noch die leibrente von
wir haben mit zwei mark angefangen für
eine kassette pro tag das war damals das
feature von video geholt und da haben
wir in jedem laden denn überall wo die
städte vertreten war diesen preis
genommen und den haben wir mit einem
euro heute noch im ersten laden hatten
wir ungefähr anderthalb tausend
videokassetten und immer schön
zurückgespult zurückbringen obwohl es
bei uns nie bestraft wurde
bei der konkurrenz musste man auch wie
geld dafür zahlen na ja bei uns war dass
wir haben zwar du sagt und studien würde
zurück weil der nächste kunde wieder
ankam der war nicht umgesprungen einmal
wollte ein kunde geld von mir haben weil
an zurückspulen musste ich saßen jetzt
aber es passiert halt mal
dann mit den dvds gab es nochmal durch
den schuldner formen ja ich mache also
das waren euch die am boden gegenüber
der videokassette weil es eben noch
kleiner war als das medium die qualität
war besser als du hast nicht diese risi
videokassette gehabt wiederum schleppen
musste ist und die auch anfällig war
[Musik]
wenn es das nicht geben würde
richtig gesagt haben wahrscheinlich wird
zu sehen das ist so eine kleine nische
gibt vielleicht bleibt noch um kleiner
laden irgendwo im keller laden sonst
etwas wo man hingehen kann und sich den
film holen kann
und ansonsten weiß ich nicht was da wie
sich das entwickelt wird
[Musik]
erstmal möchte ich etwas anderes finden
ich auch wenn du lange zeit bestand
ausgemacht da habe ich jetzt keine
perspektive und dann wartet um glaube
ich auf arbeitsmarkt jetzt für den 53
jahre alten video tk denke ich mal sind
die schuhe sind auch nicht so gut wie
sicher gestellt werden dass so viele
leute gesucht werden viele denken hoch
dass du denn neben den letzten 29 jahre
hinter dem tresen ist dass pornos guckt
und mit mir freuen wenn ich noch ein
paar leute glücklich machen könnte der
zukunft die dann sich dann doch
vielleicht noch daran erinnern dass er
noch einen videorekorder unter ihrem
fernseher haben da diese schwarze kiste
die da steht oder ein dvd-player und
dann mal herkommen und sich so für ein
hohn
[Musik]